turning to new mexico where the nation's
largest wildfire continues to burn with
bone dry and windy conditions fire crews
there are having trouble containing the
fire president biden has already issued
a disaster declaration and fema teams
are on the ground justin michaels from
our partners at the weather channel is
in new mexico with more
plumes of smoke dot the skyline of
northern new mexico the flames of two
fires the hermit's peak and calf canyon
have now merged making it the largest
wildfire burning in the country this has
been a nonstop fight day and night fire
information officer ryan berlin says the
fire's path and inconsistent weather
have been a constant obstacle to contain
the flames this fire is in some very
rugged terrain that it's inaccessible
and mother nature's with the winds is
throwing us punches we're building
containment lines on top of containment
lines the region has been in an extreme
drought since the summer of 2020 that
coupled with high temperatures bone dry
humidity and strong wind gusts means
crews need all the help they can get
it's an assault from the air and the
ground you can see the black hawk
helicopter taking off with a bucket full
of water going to an active fire line
trying to work hard to put that out some
of the 1700 personnel on the ground and
in the air are working hard in this
section of new mexico to work against a
fire that right now has the upper hand
cindy collins who lives in a town just
12 miles away from the fire says the
fires are especially tough to take after
a cold and gray winter now fire
and springtime and the spring is just a
celebration
and here we are in spring
everyone's garden is dying and there's a
huge roaring fire for cbs mornings i'm
the weather channel's justin michaels in
las vegas new mexico